it's time to talk raiders it is game day
the las vegas raiders taking on the
baltimore ravens at home at a legion
stadium lots of exciting things
happening all day long leading up to
kickoff we have team coverage this
afternoon we'll have ron futrell in just
a moment bianca holman also standing by
with what you need to know before you
get into the game bianca good afternoon
hey good afternoon john so folks have
already started to show up you can see
some people tailgating they've already
shut down some roads but
no coven 19 vaccine means no entry here
to the stadium that's why the team has
an alternate screening process because
they want you in the game
before you can join the sea of silver
and black in the stands you must have at
least one shot of your coveted vaccine
raiders leadership says it's all about
keeping everyone safe if you're fully
vaccinated you can upload your id and
vaccination card to the clear health app
but if you have trouble or only one shot
or your child is 12 or 13 you must use
the alternate screening process set up
in the white tents at the stadium fans
can also get their first or second shot
before kickoff the raiders held a two
day of alternate screenings over the
weekend this will hopefully ease the
lines fans see on game day here's what
folks had to say about the process so
far we didn't want to wait in a big line
on monday so we thought we'd come now
get it done and then we could just enjoy
ourselves on monday without being
stressed about the whole thing it went
fast it was very organized
they were if you had any questions they
answered everything right then and there
and so on game day it's going to be an
easy process
all right so alternate screening begins
in an hour if you only have one shot of
the vaccine you must wear a mask so keep
that in mind and also if you're bringing
your kids infants to all the way 11
years old remember they must also keep
on their mass while they're in the
stadium reporting live from allegiance
stadium bianca holman 8 news now go
raiders
bianca thank you very much looks pretty
crowded out there already and part of
the crowd is our own ron futrell we got
to talk about the game as well here
raiders ravens at allegiant ron good
afternoon to you looking forward to the
first game with fans
hey
yes hey there john we're about about a
block
west of the stadium here on diablo near
valley view you can see the stadium
behind us it's interesting here in the
industrial area a lot of tailgate
parties being held here a lot of parking
taking place here on occasionally
we find a couple of former raiders here
at this event for fan fest vegas
we got greg townsend and bob golick with
us here
raider legends okay yes am i right
okay
greg uh defensive lineman tell me what
the fans are in for tonight here in
vegas with this event they enforced
shocker tonight because you know though
the other uh teams won last uh yesterday
so we got to win tonight so everybody's
coming out with the a game tonight so be
rare the a game is on tonight and bob
defensive lineman you you are one of the
best in the business all pro like greg
your thoughts what a vegan what is vegas
in for tonight well first off i'd like
to
tell the the ownership that i'm still
here giving out giving out advice
but to mark davis yes i'm still here but
you know what i i think fans are fans i
think they wherever they go they've been
i mean all the people are in this
stadium the majority of them have been
to been the games before and the fact
that this year we can fill it up with
people and it's going to be regular it's
going to seem it's going to be a regular
game people are going to be excited and
it's going to they're not going to need
any coaching they're going to go fall
right into place he looks a lot like the
saved by the bell guy doesn't he to you
doesn't he does look so bad
mike rogers
college here we go signing autographs
here tonight fanfest vegas.com
is where you can go for this tailgate
party there's a lot of them happening
here reporting live just west of
allegiance stadium ron futrell eight
news now ryan thank you very much the
saved by the bell reference was not on
the bingo card this afternoon but we
appreciate it also at the game today
music legend gladys knight shall perform
the national anthem before kickoff and
above allegiant stadium you'll hear and
of course if you're outside you'll see
the fighter jets from nellis air force
base they'll fly over the stadium right
before the game so if you're heading to
the game tonight also you need to know
about the bag policy at allegion stadium
you can use clear plastic bags or fanny
packs
clear ones or a one gallon plastic
freezer bag to bring your stuff inside
small women's clutches are allowed but
do not bring a large purse or a large
backpack you won't be allowed to bring
it in